So let's have a deeper
look at CSS sizing.
I've given this image a fixed size.
640 by 360 pixels,
which is the natural size of the image.
It looks great.
But of course, when I resize the window,
the image gets cropped and
remember the problem we had earlier?
On a phone,
the image is larger than the view port.
Which means that to see the whole image,
you have to scroll horizontally.
Let's try relative sizing.
I set the image width to 100%.
It looks good in the smaller browser
window and looks good on the phone.
But, when I resize the image larger
by resizing the browser window.
It starts to get pixelated and blurry.
Let's do something about that.
If we set the max-width of the image
to 100%, the image will expand nicely,
but only ever as wide
as its natural width.
Two simple things you
can learn from this.
For devices such as laptops and
desktop monitors,
don't assume the window size is
the same as the screen size.
And don't assume the window
size will always stay the same.
Using max-width can be a good
way to respond gracefully to
a change to a larger view port.
When you're thinking responsibly,
consider large displays
as well as small.
So what if you want two
images to fit side by side,
no matter the size of the view port?
Well, that's easy.
Just use relative sizing, 50% width.
But what if you want to add a ten
pixel margin between the images?
You can just add margin-right,
10 pixels, right?
You can get around this
with our old friend calc.
Calc allows you to do simple
calculations in CSS values.
And that's a great way to combine
absolute and relative values.
For example, combining a percentage
width with a fixed margin.
Now the calculation here
looks a little complex.
But all we're saying is to give each
image a half of the width available.
I've also used the last-of-type selector
to ensure there's only a margin
between the images and
none to the right of the second image.